all right Tyler
oh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I'm originally from
Lexington Kentucky it's where the
University of Kentucky is tell me about
your family
uh my father is a veterinarian an equine
veterinarian he works with the horses uh
my I have a sister and uh now my mom and
father have remarried and I have two
stepbrothers but you know very
supportive on both sides uh
uh they they live in uh they're kind of
spread out my sister works in Texas as a
physician's assistant
and then my father's still in the
Kentucky and my mother's in South
Carolina sounds like a good family yeah
I have a really a great family yeah yeah
good chocolate I did I did how'd you end
up down here well
I
uh went to the University of Kentucky I
graduated in 2008 and I went to law
school at the North Chase College of Law
at Northern Kentucky University and
during the time that I was in law school
I
became I was in a car accident and I got
addicted to prescription painkillers and
since then it's you know uh I've been on
and off of them uh but I've been on I
was on Suboxone for about
for about five years
and uh about a year ago I relapsed on
onto the Fentanyl and uh just that's
where in the in by the nature of you
know my routine it's like I come down
here to pick up and uh it's like I just
you know I found myself spending more
and more time down here into where it's
like
it's just uh the lifestyle it's scary
how fast they can grab a hold of you
that's such a common such a common way
for people to get addicted
starting out with your painkillers and
yeah it's it's crazy when you look at
the comparison of how it was during that
time to now but I think now it's it's
they can't even write a prescription for
more than three days at a time so even
if someone who's on uh you know uh
maintenance for say like of Lortab or a
Percocet the doctor in some states will
have to actually write like 10 three day
prescriptions for them paper if they
have a 30-day script yeah they've
climbed down on that versus back then
they would give you like 60 pills for
three three refills on it and I think
anything of it you know and it's just
it's just it's really sad like that
but I don't know
did you have moments where you were
clean yeah oh yeah that's like I've been
uh
I was on uh I had I went about four to
five years without any type of relapse
at all uh not too too long ago or yeah
right before I like up in from 2016 to
2000
uh 2021 I uh
I I wouldn't say I had I had brief
periods of sobriety during that time
where I was completely completely sober
but I had other slips with like alcohol
and things like that but as far as
opiates I was completely off obvious for
the whole time no slips or anything like
that that was before fentanyl came into
the picture yeah yeah
are there addicts in your family
um I have
no no not with the panko there's there's
some alcoholism and maybe like in like
uh on my mom's side like a little bit
and then they're maybe like I have like
an uncle or two on maybe my father's
side but but not not really not really
nobody nobody's really is a the Dr has
had issues with drugs like I have like
uh but uh
yeah no no where do you live now where
do you stay
I've been staying at the uh tiny home
community
in Westlake but as of like the last
couple months I've just been been on on
transient like I just kind of like go
where
go wherever I fall fall asleep I'll
sleep a lot of times like in the train
station and like I don't know I'm really
trying to get
get a hold of things but it's just like
I feel like uh it's just uh there's
there's a lot of times that I just I
just can't believe that like the
shambles my life is in but I I am
hopeful that I'll be able to to pull
things together and get you know get
things going it's kind of it's got to be
so difficult for you to go from
going to law school
to living the classic homeless drug
addict lifestyle now it really really is
enough I feel like that
especially like I think these things are
going so really well for me too last
year I don't know why like what
possessed me to like
I don't know what possession like I I
that's the thing within all that people
I think is really
it's misunderstood in so many ways
because uh
even the people I think that do it don't
realize that how powerful uh a drug it
is and like it's like because back I
remember when uh Suboxone I guess back
when I was you know I first kind of got
into the prescription pills obviously
with the prescription pills that you
know that you know what they are 100 and
uh but to say if you couldn't the
Suboxone was strong enough that we're
say you you did you wanted to get off
the prescription pills you could take us
about you take like half of Suboxone and
you would feel no illness or whatever
and with defendant it's a longer acting
it's because it's a designer opioid and
it's not an actual traditional uh opiate
I guess because but it's it's so much
the Suboxone also it provides a blockade
effect for so say that you taking
Suboxone is directed for like a couple
weeks and it builds up in your system
you can't get high off heroin you can't
get high off oxycontin or whatever but
the fentanyl's so strong it'll you can
actually use with it and it's it's uh
I've seen they've done some research on
on it as far as like Suboxone have a
much greater or much lesser uh affected
curbing the usage of uh fentanyl but
it's just this is a totally different
beast and I think I think that's the way
this design and that's another thing too
is it
is it all the stuff that people are
using on the streets it's not the same
fentanyl that they have like in the
operating room it's all designer drugs
and analogs and stuff and stuff like
that so it's like people don't it's it's
really uh I heard there's lots of
inconsistencies yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
how old do you know I'm 37 yeah 37. have
you been living this life or some form
of it for how long about about a year no
yeah I say but before and it's not like
everything's going like great before it
but like I say things that that I'd say
I've been on a down up until 20 20 right
around town the pandemic started that's
I was I was pursuing like professional
bodybuilding I weighed about 220 I say
since then then to now where it's like
away like less like 155 is like the
least I've weighed like I can't ever
remember when that is that you know that
light and it's like uh so I'd say yeah
that's really I'm not gonna blame the
pandemic but it's just kind of when
things started to go south out I was
doing really well before prior to that I
was I was working as a I was selling
solar panels and uh
and I was living in South Carolina for
like about for a little while and then
I'll move back here right around the
pandemic started
so law school and bodybuilding and and
now you're here are you a bit of an
overachiever or
um type A personality yeah I would say
so and that's that's uh that's why that
I I haven't really been pursuing the the
profession law and professional capacity
but I really I do feel like that it's
great it's a great education it's
universally applicable and it's still I
mean it benefits there's a lot of
benefits with it uh more recently like
my my goals and now I actually do have a
clothing company uh called skulls and
diamonds and uh I've been you know have
an LLC and like I've been I've been
doing pretty well with that we're trying
to get it things going with that but
it's obviously it's been on the back
burner but I have
I haven't given up 100 with this how
does this
change in your life uh affect you
emotionally
it's it's really it's really difficult
uh you know I feel like in a lot of ways
like
I just get so it's a
I try to always
you know keep a good uh
what's the word perception or perception
or perspective perspective but it's like
it's really the things that crushes me
is just thinking knowing what I do like
my my mom like in my other family like I
don't you know I don't know that like I
should have my priorities and like I
didn't worry about myself but like I
just I just it just breaks my heart the
way that she has to see
what I go through is it's really it's
really
it's that's the worst thing for it for
me they can like and and there are a lot
of times where I just like like
wondering how did I how did I get to
this point but it's like but on the
other hand like
I try to I try to keep
it it could be really easy for me to get
overwhelmed and just be like totally
down on myself and I don't want to make
excuses for and say this everything I'm
doing is okay but I try to do try to
look at the Silver Lining and think
about the there has been some good and
maybe God put me in this position for a
reason I know that they're without any
exaggeration I can think of it right off
the top
five people's lives I've saved within
the last year being around uh and in a
couple of instances where people didn't
want to try to help them you know it's
like seeing someone overdose and they're
afraid that like if they called the 911
the police are going to come over but
you know I probably I've never given
I've given probably three or four people
CPR and administered Narcan so I mean
and that that's that's like conservative
I know I can think right I know there's
probably I know there's more than that
but like and then also like I hope that
I hope that I can get through this and
be a source of inspiration for other
other people and and really like I feel
like a lot of the uh
this a lot of the knowledge I've gained
in perspective I've gained you maybe
couldn't get it any other way than you
go through yourself and so that's kind
of like the hope I'll have I know I need
to put action behind it but
but yeah it's it but to answer your
questions which is really really
difficult emotionally and it's just like
it it's been difficult for sure do you
have kids no I don't have any kids no
kids you've been in love or anything
like that was it have you been in love
before yeah yeah that that's kind of I
think it's kind of like what kind of
kick-started this the spiral I was in a
really serious relationship
uh in South Carolina right before uh
because the pandemic started and it's
like it's uh we we had a condo like
right on the beach and like it was you
know we were going to the gym and like
and I think it's got kind of been like
ever since the uh
me and her had separated uh I haven't
really like I hadn't had much interest
in dating and I think that I don't know
like that's definitely it's been a
contributor I think like but
but yeah I have been a love to answer
your question yeah do you uh still have
contact with your family
yeah yeah I do I do that and I I talked
uh right now I don't have a phone I
don't know people see here that I think
it's so insane and crazy you know but
like I don't have a phone and like I'm I
I uh but but when I when I have a phone
I'll call my mom every day and like but
I don't have any types of uh
there's no like what I'm trying to say I
don't have any resentments or problems
within my family at all I I haven't like
I haven't been there to visit in a while
but
yeah so it's awesome are they aware of
your situation
um yeah yeah they are yeah yeah I I the
I've been thinking about going into have
you heard of eyeball game before I've
been thinking about going to do the Iowa
game and I've been
I found okay that's that's my that's my
hope I'm hoping that that can kind of
help with uh
I was getting through the situation
helping helping out with the situation
but that's that's that's something I'm
looking at on looking at on the horizon
does it does a fentanyl addiction feel
that make you feel hopeless
it does in a lot of ways like but in a
lot of ways I think that the biggest one
of the biggest pitfalls about this
lifestyle is that
it gives it gives the user some source
of a sense of like a purpose and a comp
same sense in like in the way that
somebody who's going to you know work to
have their task for their job and like
it's like you know you go out here and
like people get their little money
together and then they get their money
together it's like it's like you have a
little it's crazy it sounds use your own
like a little routine going it's where
it's like somebody maybe and I know it's
not any type of like
there's no there's no like uh uh
betterment with this itself it's all
destructive but at the same time it's
like you know you have it keeps you busy
you know in a sense where it's a
distraction I guess from anything what
does your typical day look like
um typical day like uh right now like
we're out of like I'll I'll get up
pretty early and I'll go out like uh
sometimes I'll go
uh you know all of a sign like ask for
ask for change or like or I'll go like
maybe like do like a little odd job or
do do something to try and make a little
money and then uh go get high and uh
try to uh
well it's that's the thing I think not
having a phone is like he like really
it just allows you to make excuses to
yourself it's like I'm sorry I'm kind of
stumbling over my response because I'm
trying to answer you as honestly as I
came up making excuses and trying to uh
yeah it's hard because sometimes you're
going to be so desperate for
your drug that you're going to do things
that are just beyond yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's that's for sure that's for sure
it's just like it's like it's just
it's just a
it is it's true it's true you know like
it's it's not it's not and the thing
that's crazy about it is you got
probably I don't know if the figures are
you know hundreds of thousands of people
with that same mindset and like and I've
got
I I have a pretty compassionate person
but you know I've done things as far as
like that I'm not proud of and like but
there are people out here it's just so
Cutthroat like like last night I I
typically not not too long ago maybe two
or three weeks ago I got beat up with
baseball about two people with baseball
bats and like they they could have if
they would have just asked me to take my
stuff I would have given I had like at
the time I had a crew like I had a
laptop I purchased and like I had like
backpack I had a couple of things and
like like they they beat me like they
could it could have killed me I think
and like because they kept hitting me
after after I told him to stop they took
I mean they took my jacket off me and
took my hat off me then they took my
laptop and all that but like I always
just couldn't believe it because like
they were so young they did that but uh
what was I saying I was just saying what
was the question you asked like what
kind of things have you done dude oh
yeah yeah yeah and then uh but you know
I would never I would never do that to
harm somebody but like I've you know
I've done things like as far as like
uh yeah I don't want to incriminate
myself but like just just uh
boosting yeah yeah everybody's boosting
yeah yeah yeah
what's uh what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear is
there something were to happen to uh
I was worried about my mom like her
house is not that great just to think
that
then I'll be contributing to her her dad
or her negative
because she worries about me so much
it makes me feel so bad but just I
haven't talked to her in a couple weeks
if something were to happen to her and
it and I hadn't spoken to her I just I
just
and I don't know like
I I don't I just I feel like that's my
biggest fear and also what makes me feel
just so bad is just to think that I
think it's one it's one thing to be
absent from your family and to just not
be around to support but to be actively
causing damage and to be to be a bad
source of
it's so bad I mean it's so bad that I
think I think there's there's been times
that we've had conversations where I've
told her just to like I don't know like
I can't
I don't that's my biggest fear though is
that something were to happen to someone
in my family where I hadn't where I have
been neglectful the relationship and
like to think that I was causing you
know cause them just the fact yeah
they're causing me a type of pain or
suffering or worry and it's just like
it's like a you know there's a big
motivation for me to get things together
but it's just it's difficult
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I don't think I I would be a lot more
wary of
and I'm I'm not going to put any blame
on to uh doctors or whatever because but
like I I feel like the way that you know
I've I've always had this idea I deal
like the if it came from a doctor it
says there's nothing wrong with it like
it's like I know that when I first did
uh you know like Adderall and like is it
amphetamine but I was like oh I remember
when I was younger and like we're trying
it was like oh this is 80d medicine they
give it to kids so they're thinking it's
harmless or like but I used to be a lot
more wary of any type of like synthetic
chemical
substance and I thought you know I think
that uh
I think I've taken so much for granted
this is you know I would be a lot more
mindful of what how good the uh
how good that uh
I the things were and then also just uh
but as far as I guess just trying
it's hard to think about how like to how
I would do things that with it with the
perspective without having gained the
experience
so so in a way I feel like that
you've learned from all your mistakes
yeah yeah definitely definitely so it's
hard to say like what like I would do I
guess that's the biggest thing though is
that because my mom's like that she
doesn't take any she refuses to take any
medication or anything like that and
like I think he's trying to just adhere
to that I guess yeah listen to my mom
more probably that's that's the best way
I can sum it up
and Tyler what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
that no matter what the situation is uh
you're in someone else always has it
worse than you and no matter what you've
done or doing that you can always be of
help to someone and I think that that's
that
that's the source that that's the
solution
to a lot of issues that people have I
think and it cannot but it's all and
it's also you know it's a benefit to
others but it's just a
that when you that I'm trying to say
that to be to be no matter what type of
position you're in you can always help
someone who's less fortunate than you
all right Tyler thank you so much for
sharing your story sure wish you the
best of luck thank you thank you